These easy-to-write FSMs that we've been using
that involve epsilon transitions or ambiguity--
remember, ambiguity means that I can go to 2 different places on the same input--
are formerly known as non-deterministic finite state machines.
Non-deterministic here just means that you may not know exactly
where to go or where to put your finger.
It's not lock-step. You have choices.
You have freedom.
A lock-step FSM with no epsilon transitions
and no ambiguity by contrast is called a deterministic finite state machine.
Everything is determined from the start.
Given the finite state machine and the input, you always know
exactly what will happen.
Our finite state machine simulation procedure can handle
deterministic finite state machines.
That makes them really useful for implementing regular expressions
under the hood.
Let me just show you an example of this non-determinism just to drive it home.
Suppose we were back here in this previous finite state machine,
but now the input is 1-23.
Where are we?
We started here, and on a 1 we went here,
and then I guess if we're supposed to stay alive and there's a hyphen,
we must have gone here and taken the hyphen.
And now there's a 2, but now this is really not obvious.
I could stay here on this self-loop for a 3,
or I could have gone back on this free epsilon transition
and done the self-loop here on a 3, so I could be in state 2 or state 5.
Since there isn't one single answer for where I could be,
this is non-deterministic.
As a bit of a fun aside, this notion of determinism
or non-determinism can be related to the question of free will in philosophy.
Can we actually make independent choices?
Or is everything preordained by the current state of the world
and forces acting on it, like a lock-step game of billiards or snooker or pool?
Some philosophers will approach this by suggesting that we have
the illusion of free will--that's a disconcerting thought--
which is handy for describing subjective experience.
We certainly often feel like we have free will.
Regardless of what's going on in the real world,
we're going to see that something similar holds
for finite state machines.
Although non-deterministic finite state machines look like they have
much more power and much more freedom,
anything that could be done with them could also be done
in our deterministic billiard ball world.
In fact, you can watch me suck free will out of this world right now.
Every non-deterministic finite state machine
has a corresponding deterministic finite state machine
that accepts exactly the same strings.
Non-deterministic finite state machines are not any more powerful
than deterministic finite state machines.
They're just more convenient.
It's easier to write them down.
Let's see an example of this extraordinary claim.
Suppose we have this regular expression.
There are only 2 strings in the language of this regular expression,
but here I've drawn out a very elaborate finite state machine for it
that has epsilon transitions coming out the wazoo.
This is very non-deterministic.
We definitely need to see an a, but then here these 2 epsilon transitions
represent the explicit choice.
Do I do the b, or do I skip over it?
On the top road, we need to see the b.
On the bottom road, we skip entirely past it.
And then in any event, we need to see the c.
I'm now going to write a deterministic finite state machine
that does exactly the same thing, and I'm going to hint at
how this conversion works.
We'll see this again in just a minute.
After I see an a, I could be in 2,
or I could take the epsilon to 3.
I could have taken the epsilon down here to 6
or all the way over to 4, so there are 4 places
I could be in.
That's a lot of fingers.
I'll just record all of them as the name for my new state, 2364.
From here, if I see a b and I survive--remember, finite state machines work
if there's any path that gets to the end--it must have been that I was in state 3,
at which point now I'm just in state 4.
By contrast, if I was back here and I saw a c,
it must have been that I was in state 4, and now I'm in state 5.
And then finally, if I'm in state 4 and I see a c,
I end up here, so this deterministic finite state machine
accepts the same language as the one above.
The 2 strings, a, b, c, and a, c
are both in it, but it does not have
epsilon transitions or ambiguity.
In any particular node, there are never 2 edges going out labeled a,
and there are never epsilon transitions.
Let's see another example of how this works.
Again, I'm going to build a deterministic machine
where every state in the deterministic machine
corresponds to a set of states
in the non-deterministic one.
Again, to restate that, you give me a non-deterministic machine,
I'm going to build you a deterministic machine d
that accepts the same language, and the way I'll do it is
every state in d is going to correspond to a set of states
in the non-deterministic machine you gave me.